[Music]
hello everybody to me there's a royal
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorbet of this you know we were like you
were bothered by the Rachel and comfort
and you were like let's just get this
Landis man in the world out there
is there a see-through man in the middle
team I was working on it he talks from
the back of history doesn't know what
I'm not divorced technically but I left
the house so I hope she knows that we're
getting a divorce
at the store I also got molested if we
want to lighten it up this one's funny
we were only married for seven months so
that's like a goofy amount of time to be
married 23 year-old improviser it's fine
you guys I think we thought we were kind
of like Kevin Spacey in type of right
pen or whatever it Robin pen with Robin
right pervades Stamos in house of cards
don't ever watch it it'll ruin your man
[Music]
it's great it's the best first of all
you might know this when you get a
divorce everybody's okay with you kind
of being a dirtbag for a couple months
yeah but you can just smoke and drink
and do whatever and everybody's like
you're going through something you're
like yeah I'm going through something
cancel anything yeah I canceled gigs
where I was like I can't come at the
show I got a divorce yeah
[Music]